hey everyone it's Mike from Immortal
Falls here and welcome back to my
channel I'm glad you could join me for
today's video I'm going to be giving you
guys a special treat I'm going to show
you how to get access to one of my
trading courses that I created uh
earlier this year
and in today's video I'm going to be
talking about the go charting
platform
and what you're going to get when you uh
watch this video so before I jump in
um if you've been enjoying my videos be
sure to subscribe to the channel click
the notification Bell so you don't miss
any new uploads and hopefully I know
you'll find today's video helpful so you
know be sure to hit the like button and
leave some comments
um in the comments section sharing your
biggest takeaway I love hearing your
feedback so let's go ahead and get
started with today's topic all right so
the go charting platform right it's a
brilliant addition to the the trading
world right we all want to you know
we're all connected to the web and the
problem with a lot of trading platforms
or charting platforms is that it has to
be downloaded and installed on your PC
and you know if you're on the go or if
you travel and you want to stay in touch
with the markets you know it's kind of a
pain in the butt because you got to have
um you know different PCS you got to
have a laptop if you're traveling and
you know and you just want to keep in
touch with the market it's you know a
big added expense in that sense and the
go charting platform it's a web-based so
you can access your charts uh from
anywhere without having to install
anything right you just go to the URL go
charting you log into your account and
you're gonna be able to pull up a
footprint chart just like this right and
if you subscribe to the
um order flows Trader footprint uh
package you know you're going to get all
my order flow tools and really what
makes the go charting platform so
special right is because it's it's
created by Traders for Traders right
the guys at gochart you know they
understand order flow and that's
important because you know I see a lot
of software out there that is available
for Traders and they have a quote
footprint chart you know they call it
all different names
um but you know it's just something that
they put in there as a as a gimmick but
you know it's something to say oh yeah
look our software has a footprint chart
but to be honest the guys that go
charting even without my order closed
Trader software right even before they
added my gold my order closed Trader uh
package right they already had a pretty
decent and robust software in terms of
order flow analysis and to be honest
there's a few things that I even picked
up
um from their software that I that I
like to use in my own trading or not
going to get into that right now
um because what I want to talk about is
a trading course that you could get for
free that I created specifically for go
charting customers and you know we give
it away because you know we hope that
you'll want to use go charting as well
and if you just go to this URL here
www.orderflows.com gocharting
right that's going to take you to the
page where you can sign up for free so
just go to uh go charting whoops the
orderflows.com
orderflows.com slash gocharting right
that's all you got to do and it's going
to redirect you to this page where you
just enter your name and email address
and hit sign up and you're gonna be
taken right to the actual trading course
it's a five lesson course it's not uh
you know something it's I think the
total of about three hours there is a
total of uh five modules in it
that you know really get in depth on a
footprint right because a lot of people
say Mike you know can you teach me sort
of the basics of footprint well that's
why I created uh this course and it's
specific to the go charting
platform so if you're interested in
understanding go charting I really take
you through
um you know how to use the go charting
platform to read the order flow what I
like to look for in the order flow okay
so again you know if you're interested
in go charting right now
um you know just go to go charting you
could sign up right now my order flows
Trader software suite is available for
free for another couple of weeks before
it goes to a paid subscription
but for now you know for the next couple
weeks you can still access it for free
now let me just uh
do what I'll go through here yeah so
basically that's it enter your name your
email and hit sign up now granted you
know you'll be joining my email list so
um you know you will get notifications
you know when we do have specials going
out right now but again you know the go
charting platform is a great tool if you
want to follow the markets
on a mobile device on your iPad if
you're traveling the subscription isn't
very much for their data you know
they've got different pricing plans you
can subscribe to the CME data here if
you want equities and ETFs right you can
subscribe there because people always
ask me Mike you know can you do uh
something on QQQ
you know how the footprint if there's
going to be a footprint right now okay
yeah here we go
um 4X right say you want I don't know
Hong Kong dollar versus uh well what's
up what's our things here Hong Kong
versus there you go
let's choose one
Hong Kong Euro versus Hong Kong dollar
right see if there's any
what we're going to come up for that
the second sometimes when it first pulls
in the data
there we go all right you got to expand
it up a bit now again when you're
looking at Forex you will probably want
to you probably do need to make an
adjustment on
pick manager right sort of go to auto
mode
um crypto
see my favorite
chip people ask me you know hey am I
invested in crypto well yeah I've
still well that's a bit stamped for
crypto what I recommend if you're doing
uh anything if you're trying to analyze
crypto you'll have choices coinbase
bitmax bitstamp Finance
I stick to the coinbase one because
obviously I'm in the US so my accounts
with coinbase
um
right again when you're looking at
crypto you will probably need to make
some adjustments to uh the thick manager
auto block size over time I'm going to
be making more videos on you know
specific markets
um you know which what's
as far as tick size
um you know if you're interested in
Nifty okay I know a bunch of guys
trade Nifty
right there you go
Nifty Footprints I'll be making
um
actually in the course I think I did
talk about Nifty a little bit but
in the future
um look for me I will be offering some
making some videos on Nifty and Bank
Nifty and what you should be looking at
in the order flow okay because it does
uh does have its own little nuances
that's going to be different from CME
and
um you know obviously some of the other
markets right so for example right euro
currency
trades one way
right
your currency data is pretty pretty
solid right and it's easy to see with
the order flow but when you're getting
into markets like Bank Nifty and uh
regular Nifty I think there's uh there's
little nuances that do need to be
explained a bit so
um you know be on the lookout if you're
interested in Nifty and Bank Nifty just
be sure to subscribe to the channel so
when those videos come out uh you'll be
notified okay but again you know go
charting if you're interested in go
charting go to gocharting.com and sign
up and then once you do if you're
interested in adding my indicators right
now they're for free you're going to
open up a chart which first thing you're
going to do is add cluster
right to give you a footprint chart
because when you start you may just
start with a normal uh Candlestick chart
that looks like this with
um obviously no footprint so what you
got to do is you got to add cluster then
to get the order closed Trader right you
just go down to study click on order
flow go to order flows Trader
okay and it's going to add in the order
flow Trader
um
tools okay and you can like I said you
could play around with it for the next
couple of weeks until it goes to a paid
version and again to get the
trading course the link is in the
description below
orderflows.com slash gocharting
and it's going to take you
uh whoops
what did I do there
um
okay it's going to take you to that page
right here
I'm going to redirect you to this page
get the go charting order flow trading
course for free just enter your best
email and get the immediate access to go
charting uh oracle's trading course all
right so again you know like I said I
had something special for you in this
video
so thanks for watching being a part of
my community your support is appreciated
and I'll see you in the next videos but
until then keep working towards your
trading goals and remember you know
you've got this trading is a journey
it's not a final destination you don't
get to the point where
you know everything you know my it's
funny I got a seven-year-old kid and he
thinks he knows everything all right
kids nowadays they think they know
everything I'm like us boy you you don't
know what you don't know so
um and it's the same way in trading
right you don't know what you haven't
learned so you know that's why I created
this course so people can understand
um you know how to read the order flow
better right because at the end of the
day we always want to improve ourselves
right become a better Trader
make more money ideally is the end goal
in trading so
enjoy this free course and I'll see you
guys in the next video bye-bye